I want to know how you would handle
something we were on the show we were
watching this video have you heard all
right
have you heard the phrase catch me
outside how about that catch me outside
cash me out cash me out son how about
that no what does it mean so we're
watching this this troubled 13-year old
girl on the dr. Phil show yes and she's
calling the audience hos she's saying
catch me outside how about that as in
like I'll fight you guys all right we
get outside yes and I want you to watch
a little bit of it okay and I and I
would love if you could explain how you
would provide guidance you've raised you
know a bad seed all right now if she put
on or do you believe this is her this is
her okay because we've seen other videos
since dr. Phil show that she just made
it okay terrific
and it's her so she doesn't look 13 no
no believe me I've had to say that to a
judge you are fast I mean I kid make a
great timing thank you
all right here we go you don't leave
your keys in a print in someone's room
when they've stolen cards before like
you asking for it it's talking about
stealing cars um so what do you think is
going to happen when you happen to steal
somebody's car that disagrees with that
and decides that they're going to drop a
hammer on you and prosecute you to the
full extent of the law
jellineck day that's what I always do
and they never catch me ain't nobody
gonna catch me because you're too
streetwise yup in audience laughing
life's all funny just talking about the
audience like a laughing matter did you
say that the hoes are laughing yep so
the audience are a bunch of hos yeah
[Applause]
catch me I saw how about they catch you
outside
what does that mean what'd I just say
catch her outside and she'll go outside
and do what she has to do so now yeah
that's a she's a very poorly behaved
young lady okay
so first of all I am very I feel very
sorry for her because that is such a
defensive position that it's her against
the world so somewhere either she has
her wiring is off or her upbringing that
it she was always put down or something
that is the the end the feeling I'm
getting and how sad that she is so angry
and so young when this world is so
filled with Wonder so the first thing I
would do is I would go to counseling
with her you would I would I would
that's what I would do I would you would
have to somehow recalibrate her view of
her in the world
I see so so that she knows that she's
not if she doesn't need to be in
fighting position for she is this
beautiful little girl and you know all
she wants to do is defend herself and
keep this kind of concrete wall around
her and she thinks she can just she's
out gonna outsmart everybody she's going
to beat everybody she's gonna beat up
everybody which is an impossibility
there is one day this little girl is
going to be extraordinarily hurt more
than she must be to have this view of
life I'll tell you I saw a video of her
getting pulled out of a car by her
ponytail and they said we caught her
outside so it's happened yes someone
beat her up her age right still